good afternoon everybody
thank you for joining us for this media
availability with ottawa police interim
chief steve bell
joining us the chair of the ottawa
police service board councillor eli
al-shantiri deputy commissioner chris
harkins with the opp
as well as rsmp deputy commissioner mike
du m federal policing
mercedes
and i will be your moderator
we will bring we will begin with remarks
from our chair eli and shanthiri and
then we will hear from the other
speakers
thank you very much and good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
i'm here today we just
took a drive with our mayor to check our
street
and to stop in say thank you to our
partner to our members the other police
members and all our partner it was a
good day to
to be around and see our street it's
been clear
and it feels good to feel back we are
back in our city and and we're taking
back our city but today was mostly just
to say thank you to the partner who came
as far as vancouver to come and help us
with the in the city of ottawa so on
behalf our city our resident the arab
police service board
everyone want to say thank you to the
partner we could have not done it
without your help and your assistant so
heartfelt to all our members who's been
working tirelessly in it in the last
three weeks and we want to say thank you
to their family as well
because it's not just the partners who
do their job also the partner at home
takes some of that as well so thank you
again and i'll turn it over to it
thank you
thank you
good afternoon everybody
i want to begin by thanking downtown
residents for their continued patience
they woke up this morning to fencing and
a very heavy police presence through the
downtown core
while i know that everyone is pleased to
see many of the unlawful protesters are
gone this is not the normal state of our
city
despite the successes of the past few
days we still require these measures to
prevent unlawful protesters from
returning
after a successful series of operations
yesterday the number of unlawful
protesters has dramatically declined in
the last 24 hours
last night we continued to have major
issues with a group of dispersed
protesters in the bank street area south
of queen street
many of the unlawful protesters
continued their unruly behavior with
officers who were attempting to erect
barriers and fencing in that area
the actions of the unlawful protesters
led to the deployment of an irwin
we are not aware of any injuries
city crews are clearing and plowing the
affected areas
as i said at this time
at this time checkpoints remain
throughout the city we ask residents to
respect these checkpoints and the
officers who are working there
we continue to advise unlawful
protesters that they must leave the area
immediately or they may face arrest
this morning four people entered into a
secure area and were arrested
we continue to monitor unlawful
protester activity across the city and
within the region
we are seeing the site at coventry road
currently being dismantled
at this time 191 people have been
arrested
107 people have been charged and in
total 389 criminal charges have been
laid so far
these charges include obstructing police
disobeying a court order
assault mischief possessing a weapon and
assaulting a police officer
every one of these arrests has a back
story in one incident
a protester attempted to disarm an
officer of their taser another officer
quickly intervened and assisted that
officer to ensure that the taser was
retained
the protester was arrested and several
several criminal code charges were laid
including mischief and attempt to disarm
a police officer
we are aware that the special
investigations unit has invoked its
mandate with respect to two incidents
one relates to an interaction involving
a police horse
the other relates to discharge of the
yarwin any questions relating to these
two incidents must be directed to the
special investigations unit
the provincial emergency management and
civil protection act as well as the
federal emergencies act have provided
support to our operation and its
continued viability and success
my colleagues from the ontario
provincial police and the royal canadian
mounted police will address this in
their statements
i'm proud of every member who has been
involved in assisting our efforts to
bring this unlawful protest to an end
and i continue to be impressed by the
professionalism of our officers some of
whom have been confronted with very very
difficult situations
we know that these unlawful protests
have been difficult on everyone in our
community
this has impacted residents and
communities right across ottawa
we promised earlier this week that we
would clear our streets and give them
back to our residents
we promised that we would return our
city to a state of normalcy
with every hour we are getting closer to
that goal
please note that our entire police
service remains committed to the
community healing that still needs to be
fostered and focused on in the days to
come thank you
thank you chief
i would like to thank all opp members
those in ottawa and across the province
who have been working very hard to
ensure safety and security of our
communities
i'd also like to thank the ottawa police
the rcmp members
and all of our law enforcement partners
from across canada
for the professionalism and dedication
has been shown during these trying times
while we have all been here to assist
ottawa police
the integrated command center has been
an outstanding example
of an effective partnership
has seen multiple agencies working
jointly to develop plans for this
operation
the ontario
emergency management and civil
protections act or the emcpa
has given the police the ability to take
additional action against those
participating in all unlawful assemblies
not only in ottawa but anywhere across
this province
interference with any critical
infrastructure including 400 series
highways
railways international bridges and
border crossings is prohibited
commercial vehicle driver's licenses
private driver's licenses commercial
motor vehicle
registration cvors certificates has been
suspended or cancelled
commercial and passenger vehicle license
plates can be seized
so far in ottawa a total of 76 vehicles
have been seized
and towed
these license plates have been seized
from 36 passenger vehicles
of those 12 vehicles are from ontario
and 24 are from other province vehicles
the ministry of transportation has taken
an action related to 36
commercial motor vehicles
or cbors
of those 13 commercial motor vehicle
drivers registered in ontario
and 23 are from out of province
additional warnings were issued to
commercial motor vehicle operators
regarding their status
deputy
deputy
good day everyone
i'm happy to be here today and provide
you with some information in relation to
the ongoing events and wish to share
with you
most recent stats under the emergency
act
i also echo deputy commissioner harkin's
comments of the incredible work being
done here in ottawa by everyone involved
as we have worked through this operation
in ottawa we have seen the benefits of
the emergency act
provisions of this emergency acts have
allowed us to maintain the perimeter
restrict travel and ensure that we can
continue to choke off financial support
and other assistance to protesters we
are working with law enforcement
federal partners and financial
institutions to freeze financial
products of individuals and companies
suspected of involvement in the illegal
acts mentioned in the law
we are already seeing positive results
including the freezing of 206 financial
products and what i mean by financial
products will be bank accounts corporate
accounts the disclosure of 56 entities
vehicles individuals companies
the addresses of 253 bitcoin shared with
virtual currency exchangers
and the proactive freezing of an account
of a payment processor for a value of
3.8 million dollars by financial
institution
we continue to work at collecting
relevant information on persons vehicles
and companies and remain in daily
communication with the financial
institution to assist them
information
it is
foreign
thanks for taking my questions stephen
hoff cc national news after it took you
almost three weeks to get rid of this
occupation
how do you go about restoring trucks
trust among residents and uh who expect
you to move quicker and how long do they
should they expect to see the
checkpoints and the increase increased
police presence downtown
so as i said in my in my comments
earlier on the building that community
trust and and entering into uh community
healing is an absolutely vital next step
for the ottawa police service and our
community partners uh this this unlawful
occupation of our streets has
dramatically impacted people in the
downtown core but i don't think there's
a resident of ottawa who hasn't felt the
hurt or pain that that these
demonstrators have caused to our city to
our community quite frankly to our
society
we
today as early as as late as today i've
been reaching out to community leaders
from across the city to start the
discussions about how do we start to
enter into those dialogues because they
are vitally important
we know as a police service we we have
public trust to gain back we we have
discussions dialogues learnings to do
from what happened and occurred up to
this weekend
as well as how we reform rebalance and
move forward those vitally important
community partnerships community
relations so as as the chief
and as representing every single member
of this police service we are deeply
committed to the community healing that
we know now needs to take place
um
hello
um thanks for taking our questions today
it's joining cbc news ottawa um
following on on the sort of you know how
long will the downtown be closed i see
that a lot of people are speculating
that maybe there's never going to be uh
traffic back on wellington street uh
security at parliament hill has often
spoken about that now that it's been
closed for three weeks
and i know it is the purview of
wellington street of the ottawa police
service
is there any sense that it might be
closed indefinitely
until we figure out you know how to
prevent this sort of occupation again i
notice that there are truckers there's
reports of the truckers having set up
down at vancleek hill so they're not
that far away
so one of the things that we identified
early on is we had a deliberate
well-resourced plans and commitment from
partners
i can tell you through discussions right
up to before we came down to this press
conference today there's a deep
commitment from our partners to continue
to support us
through the deputy commissioners that
i'm working here with today
through the support of commissioner
creek and commissioner lucky i can tell
you that the rcmp and opp will be
present with us till the end of this
operation and we're not done this
operation yet there is another phase
that will identify how we maintain the
streets how we eventually demobilize
once we've identified that there is no
threat of further uh protests coming to
our city we aren't there yet we will
over the next several days identify
what the posture of the police services
will look like to see how we maintain a
presence and make sure that nobody
returns to occupy our streets again
hi everyone and this is analyst at tvl
montreal can i ask my question in french
it's possible if you can ask your
english a question in english first i'll
make sure you get a response all right
no problem um
you said it's progressing very well uh
very well you say so when exactly and i
know it's difficult probably but you
must have a date a time for
a return to normal i think resident i
think people want to know that
information thank you
so i said from the beginning we we have
a plan and we're executing the plan the
one part of the plan that we don't
determine is the actual timelines of
when we complete it
we
began to execute our plan on thursday
afternoon
moved into an actions on phase on friday
morning and you've seen the results of
that over the weekend i still can't say
when
we will ultimately be completed this
operation because we now need to enter
into a maintenance portion of it to make
sure that what occurred three weeks ago
can never occur again so we will
continue to have a posture protect their
streets of our city protect our
community members from unlawful
occupations like occurred now moving
forward for as long as it takes
[Music]
good afternoon chief david menzies with
rebel news um chief can you kindly
explain how it was that my colleague to
my right here alexa lavoie was shot
point blank with a tear gas canister
doing some very painful damage to her
what was the reason for that given that
she was simply
practicing journalism in the public
square
uh so i'm unfamiliar with the incident
you're speaking of what i can tell you
is that there is complaint mechanisms
there is review mechanisms that will be
engaged following this for any use of
force incident that occurred
i'll also say that it's been my
observations and experience through the
amazing extensive journalism coverage
that's occurred through this that the
vast majority of our members have been
extremely professional they have
executed an extremely methodical plan
that has been focused on the safety of
the residents the safety of our officers
and the safety of the people engaged in
the protest and chief just one follow-up
question if i may um
given that the emergency
act requires certain benchmarks to be
met such as the safety of canadians must
be at peril
the sovereignty of the nation must be at
peril
do you think those benchmarks were met
given this was for what i could tell a
largely
peaceful demonstration and protest so i
guess i'm asking did you really need to
have this act and vote in terms of uh
what were minor unlawful uh acts and uh
basically bylaw infractions
so what the the federal government the
provincial government both uh enacted
legislation that was absolutely
supportive to helping us to end the
illegal occupation of our streets uh
what could be described as bylaw
infractions were actually terrorizing
moments for the city for the city the
residents and the communities that came
around those areas
the powers that were provided to us
through the emergencies act through the
provincial emergency act through the
injunction and through any of the other
legislative meetings that we got to end
this protest were extremely beneficial
in us being able to be where we are
today see clear streets and have
residents that can again walk through
their downtown core that they own thank
you
hi there eric ibrahim the canadian press
if
my recollection is correct
it was mentioned that
191
people were arrested at 107 are charged
i'm wondering if you can tell us about
the remaining
number in custody and and what we might
be able to expect as far as charges laid
with them
so what i can tell you is that we will
on a regular basis update our
investigative progress uh you will see
more people there will be updated uh
numbers in terms of arrests that have
occurred as a result of
unlawful protests and demonstrations
today
you will see series of charges coming
out after that and we will continue to
update on our investigations and charges
on an ongoing basis
okay thank you and just one quick
follow-up um i i have heard a report
that um police were giving um
uh perhaps a piece of paper or something
of that nature to truckers or
demonstrators as they left the perimeter
i was wondering if you could describe
what that might have been
uh so i'm i'm unfortunately i'll have to
get information for you i'm unfamiliar
what that piece of paper would be
uh peter hum with the ottawa citizen
i have some questions about protesters
that are outside of the downtown core at
the moment
i understand first of all with respect
to coventry road the encampment there
that
notices uh regarding trespassing were
delivered by police today so i'm
wondering if you could tell me first of
all
like what the situation is currently how
many protesters are there at the camp
and and then what you're expecting from
those people
so as we indicated at uh at the
beginning of this there was a methodical
plan that was going to be enacted to
take care of all of the locations that
were disrupted by the unlawful
occupation that includes coventry road
currently there is activity by our
members and activity by demonstrators to
demobilize that area and ultimately
re-secure it by the city
uh if i could follow up there are also
reports as i understand it of uh
protesters retreating to property in
kinburn and as well there's
been reports in the past about
protesters in umbreon on i believe
private property there can you tell me
what
what can police do about those
protesters
so
we have an active we have active
intelligence investigations ongoing to
ensure that we know where people are
leave that people are leaving if they
are trying to amass again to return to
the the downtown core so while we
maintain our footprint in this area to
protect the downtown streets we are
trying to are attempting to keep tabs on
those that are leaving and being
potentially massing to come back we will
continue those efforts through our
partnership with the rcmp and the opp
continue to gather intelligence to make
sure that these uh illegal activities
don't return to our streets
i'd just like to make one just to make a
couple more last comments if you don't
mind please so um
first of all what i'd like to say is uh
the the media coverage the participation
from the media throughout this has has
been quite incredible um the the
documentation of the activities that are
going on has given people the real life
experience of what's occurring out there
so for that i thank you i also know the
media has been subjected to
slurs
to abuse to illegal activities to
themselves so we have one active
investigation ongoing right now and i
would ask that if there are any more
activities that need to be reported
please report to the ottawa police
service because we will take them
seriously and conduct an investigation
around those activities
i have to thank the officers that came
here
it's nothing short of incredible the
people that showed up for us
the municipalities the federal
provincial police services that actually
attended ottawa to help us take our
streets back was amazing but beyond them
i actually have to thank the communities
that they came from there are many many
people across the country that actually
let their police officers go to help the
citizens of ottawa and for that i thank
them
finally it's important for me to
recognize the community i talked about
community healing i talked about the
steps that we have to go on to move
ahead and they are many and they will be
hard and they will be long but you have
the commitment of this service to
actually engage in those there are many
steps that we have to take but they are
going to be important discussions and
dialogue so that we can heal as a
community and come together thank you
very much
um